yesterday i played a clip for you from
radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene's
off-the-wall interview with alex jones
that's the same alex jones who said
thank god you're not david pakman thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
dave pagman exactly that's the same alex
jones who now has attacked our bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad okay so
during that interview i didn't see this
clip until after yesterday's show during
that very same interview with marjorie
taylor greene
alex jones actually suggests to marjorie
taylor green what about you running for
president and marjorie taylor green
doesn't say i'm not interested take a
look at this can we get you to run for
president in
the next few years because i think i
think you're one of the few people
that would probably have a better voting
record and have a better chance of
winning than even trump or maybe a uh
green desantis
ticket oh my god
well alex i don't know what's going to
happen i'm i'm a very strong supporter
of president trump but in the future
we'll we'll definitely see what happens
by the way that's code for i would
absolutely do it but i'm not going to
run against trump what the people think
about something like that but we need a
green agenda
build back better with president greene
well we my agenda would be all for this
country i just i love our country and i
hate absolutely hate what the federal
government has done to the american
people um sure absolutely before cnn
spends that i'm not actually endorsing
their fake green agenda their comments
agenda it's a play on words yes it's a
play on words now laugh at your own
peril
laugh at your own peril because many of
us laughed off trump but you know why we
did
because we overestimated the
intelligence and common sense and
critical thinking skills of the
republican electorate
we overstated it and if you overestimate
the intelligence of the republican voter
you get burned and so if you laugh at
the idea of marjorie taylor greene as at
least as the republican nominee
just remember that donald trump did it
now we almost have to hope i mean this
is crazy we have to hope that
republicans on principle would not elect
a woman president but sadly this is
exactly the type of woman they might
elect uh she can be
their
proof
about how wrong we are about their
sexism and misogyny in the entire thing
and i i hate to say this
but
most likely
whoever replaces trump as the republican
frontrunner if trump is pushed out if
trump doesn't run it's a different thing
but if trump is pushed out
it will probably be someone who's even
worse than trump and i know that it's
hard to imagine but
when the party is so radical
and 50 60 percent of its voters are so
whacked out they still want trump to run
at this point in time they're not going
to say let's choose someone more
rational and sober than donald trump
if anything it would go in the opposite
direction and in particular when policy
no longer matters
and a very high
priority
for these folks is pick someone that
will trigger the liberals that's that's
a top priority for who they pick
um it's certainly plausible they would
go with somebody like marjorie taylor
greene if it came to it i mean remember
evangelicals
didn't care about how obviously
non-religious trump was
and how he didn't go to church
and he was pro-choice until he decided
to run for president and all this stuff
and eventually the evangelicals came
over and supported donald trump uh the
family values people didn't care about
the number of wives and divorces and
affairs that donald trump they
eventually came to came over and part of
it was we don't like hillary obviously
and part of it was let's trigger the
liberals they would be so triggered by
this so i would not laugh off the
possibility not of a marjorie taylor
green presidency although once you get
to be the nominee anything can happen as
we saw in 2016 but i would not laugh off
the possibility of a marjorie taylor
green
uh nomination
among the republican party
let me know what you think find me on
twitter at d pacman we'll take a quick
break and be back
what a friday show we have for you today
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that i have ever made coffee i've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor i really enjoy cometier they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video